want to know what's heating up in  theaters this weekend you really don't  want the treatment this Spa offers in  the horror movie a cure for Wellman says  no one is releasing what happens to come  a fight I'm sorry what Ice Cube and  Charlie Day played teachers about to  meet in the parking lot after school in  fist fight you got me I don't think he's  got this  why I use here in the Great Wall Matt  Damon plays a mercenary who joins elite  Chinese warriors fighting a mysterious  enemy  let's check out this week's for  anticipation  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  you  [Music]